yeah you uh you know early on in the
project you're talking you know for
people who don't know kind of give us
the background you lost your mom when
you were three years old mm-hmm
she was young i think you said she was
25. she was only 25. you know i'm saying
and i was only three so
your auntie helped raise you yeah my
auntie you know i'm saying which was her
sister
what happened with your mom why did she
pass so early if you don't mind sharing
[ __ ] the police man you know what i'm
saying that was 1989 you feel what i'm
saying
uh the crack epidemic was crazy you know
what i'm saying the uh
the police force in the streets was
crazy you know what i'm saying it was
just a war on drugs just for me so
anybody out
anybody out there that was selling or
using
there was a target period you know i'm
saying you go to jail get killed
in a process so your mom
was killed during an interaction with
the cops yeah man
[ __ ] man she got pulled over on some
[ __ ] man
you know what i'm saying [ __ ] i don't
think she wants to go to jail you feel
me she probably talked to him crazy
probably resisted the rest or some [ __ ]
who knows
yeah it's crazy too because like we
think about police brutality and how
over the last like
seven eight years it's been so magnified
in social media
yeah but it's it's it's crazy because
when you go back and you watch
like you know obviously not being from
la i'm from phoenix but like
watching like you know the menace to
societies the boys in the hood and like
the way
the cops were portrayed in those movies
it's like almost like it was worse back
then
and there was no cameras yeah it was
worse back then like they fabricated
how the police really act in the movies
and like
like like they dumbed it down like done
they dumb that [ __ ] down but they
over exaggerated how [ __ ] programmed
in the streets you get what i'm saying
the streets was turnt up like don't get
me wrong but you know like the movies
they made it a little bit dramatic you
feel what i'm saying
yeah um how like
you know at three years old i don't
remember much from three years old
obviously
um like what was that like though kind
of like you know like how did your
family kind of
once you were getting older like you
know what i'm saying like how do they
kind of
let you know what happened because
that's kind of a tough thing to tell a
kid on i'm like yo this is what happened
to your mom
hey you know look so that's why i kept
getting like different stories you know
what i'm saying i had to put this [ __ ]
together
because i would ask you know what i'm
saying my auntie i asked you know what
i'm saying a
cousin or uncle or somebody and i get
all
different stories right because because
you're a kid they won't they don't want
to tell you know wild [ __ ]
they're probably either sparing my
feelings or they didn't even know
um you get what i'm saying so it was
just i was getting different stories so
like the three different stories i got i
put them all together
and you know what i'm saying came down
to the bottom of that [ __ ] and i asked
my granddaddy like hey man
this like did this happen he like that's
exactly what happened you from what i'm
saying
cause they telling me she this she died
right
you know what i'm saying so once i got
the real my granddaddy was like man
that's exactly what happened like i'm
saying